and we will keep men out of women's
sports do trans women actually have an
advantage everyone assumes of course
always in every single one of these
Sports the real answer is sometimes and
the reality is that many trans women
transition early in adulthood sometimes
they don't undergo male puberty in the
same way that cisgender males do and end
up being indistinguishable from CIS
women by any casual Observer and there's
not really a concern there so with that
group and again we're subdividing
subdividing to really get to the core of
this I don't know that they
should be excluded from women's sports
league so if these early transition
trans women have no muscular Advantage
they may not have undergone male puberty
it seems they should be allowed to
participate without any issue based on
everything I've read